the left is moving in lockstep in their
sleazy effort to obliterate not only the
Supreme Court confirmation of Brett
Kavanaugh but the man himself we've seen
Soros funded activists confronting
senators and elevators to stall
Cavanaugh's confirmation choreographed
impromptu press conferences and rallies
Hollywood stars staging their tedious
walk outs to urge the Senate to vote
against Kavanagh
and now academia has engaged so watch
out a Provost distinguished professor at
Georgetown University her name is Carol
Christine fair and she's acting
everything but fair tweeted this last
weekend look at this chorus of entitled
white men justifying a serial rapist
arrogated entitlement all of them
deserve miserable miserable deaths while
feminists laugh as they take their last
gasps bonus we castrate their corpses
and feed them to swine yes so no longer
content to indoctrinate our children
academic liberals like fair are now
advocating violence against
conservatives when she was exposed by
campus reform professor fair accused
them of bullying her now as she's a
damsel in distress I thought we thought
they could take care of themselves in a
blog post she insisted my choice of
words is intended to make you
uncomfortable because I and tens of
millions of women in this country are
uncomfortable with the ongoing war on
our bodies our lives and our fundamental
freedoms so help me out here men should
have their genitals mutilated then fed
to animals to give her control over her
body she's gonna have to tell me how
that'll work now what's shocking though
is at Georgetown its standing by this
left wing nut bag are these the Jesuit
Catholic values the university is so
proud of well they claim her comments
were private and not the views of
Georgetown but this is a woman who on
social media has called Trump supporters
maggots get it
Trump pansies can you imagine if a
conservative academic if there are any
refer to Democratic politician
supporters as simians or anyone for that
matter as a monkey salerno's
roseanne an apology this dean check it
out is a true
lefty hater trump and i won't use the
the profess president what Trump has
done largely under the influence of
Israel has an everything a can to
sabotage this Iran agreement you know we
had to blur out some of those stickers
on her laptop she can't even keep those
clean and I'm sure Trump is losing sleep
over the fact that she's not calling him
President Trump all right but just as a
comparison at Catholic University also
in DC Dean will reign Ford had the nerve
to question Christine Ford's credibility
on Twitter he wrote sweat Nick is 55
years old Kavanagh is 52 years old
since when do senior girls hang out with
freshman boys if it happened when
Kavanagh was a senior sweat Nick was an
adult drinking with and by her admission
having sex with underage boys in another
youniverse he would be the victim and
she the perk well for that completely
kind of fact-based opinion Dean Rainford
was suspended by Catholic you for the
semester and forced to write an apology
and he didn't even threaten anybody's
life okay by the way a suspension that
wasn't good enough yesterday angry
protesters stormed the university
demanding that the Dean resign liberals
have infested every corner of
universities from the classroom to the
administration building we know that by
now and emboldened they operate
according to their own resistance
rulebook at least 20 year university
professors shut down classes it was last
week I guess so that law students could
protest Cavanaugh's
earrings both in DC and on campus
students were black in staged sit-ins
oh how original undergrads later marched
across campus to express their outrage
now remember Cavanaugh is a Yale alum so
this is particularly pathetic she was
very emotional during her opening
statement and to be confronted with the
first thing that Senator Grassley said
was he feels equally for Brett Kavanaugh
her alleged perpetrator as he feels for
dr. Ford who has received death threats
and she feels like unable to be safe
even in her own home and really wants
there to be an extra way for people to
exit I find that to be really striking
this happened to her decades ago and
she's still feeling the real effects of
it today $75,000 a year for tuition at
Yale University
oh my Harvard University yesterday
associate dean Catherine Claypool
announced that brick Cavanaugh will no
longer be teaching a course that he's
taught in the past at the school
Claypool claims that Cavanaugh quote can
no longer commit to his course on the
Supreme Court well no wonder this is a
university that last year months after
Trump's election hosted a resistance
school featuring leftist activists and
agitators the origin of the resistance
school lies in the election on November
8th of 2016 of the 45th President of the
United States like so many of you my
friends and I woke up on November 9th
just devastated schools our intellect
places for intellectual exchange for
social transformation and yes when
necessary for political resistance
$80,000 a year what is it at Harvard
well true to form students and alumni
have been urging Harvard Law School to
rescind Cavanaugh's teaching appointment
since the Christine Ford allegations
leaked hundreds of Harvard graduates
signed a petition
demanding that Harvard cut ties with
Cavanaugh in other words the mob got
their way for Yale and Harvard and even
Dean unfair we talked about earlier you
know what happened to this principle of
innocent until proven guilty
I thought the Liberals really believed
in that that's totally out the window
given the shaky state of these
accusations against Cavanaugh and the
daily erosion of the credibility of the
accusers why our law schools of all
places rushing to judgment against their
own alumnus without any substantiating
evidence or witnesses it's amazing if
they really wanted to teach their law
students an important lesson it might be
this put your political prejudice aside
exercise a bit of restraint and withhold
judgment until all the evidence and the
facts are in oh and justice should still
be blind not political and that's the
angle